no one point it got me a little
emotional Jennifer Lopez and Alex
Rodriguez celebrate their engagement
with family and friends
the bride and groom celebrated their
upcoming nuptials in Los Angeles on
Saturday night Ryan Seacrest and J Lo's
bestie Leah Remini were among the famous
faces of the event the couple shared
some of the sweet moments from their
gorgeous night to Instagram including as
this adorable pic with their daughters
the pair's longtime friends Carole Bayer
Sager and her hubby Bob Daly hosted the
lavish event
JLo thanked them on Instagram along with
a cute pic smooching her man writing in
part thank you for the most beautifully
elegant night we love you Rodriguez and
Lopez's engagement party comes six
months after he proposed in March
et recently spoke with Jennifer about
the important role her son Max will have
on their big day last time et spoke with
JLo she said they're still ironing out
the details of their special day we're
talking about it but we don't have any
firm places you like even years
[Music]
[Applause]
you